good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Wednesday it is hump day
so appropriate because I'm sitted seated
with three of the most humpable lovable
sexy people I know it's Bryce it's
stress it's Jax and it's Claude it is
that's so true yeah The Strokes brothers
are with us both of them in studio like
on chairs visible to the audience
watching on YouTube and yeah welcome
because these are some gorgeous boys
that you're seeing today yes it feels so
good so right it's been weeks weeks it's
been
eternities since the stripes Brethren
have been on the show and it's time
today that they get their [__] asses
up in work I know like they don't even
know how important how integral to the
business they are yeah
and today's episode is going to have a
million views and literally all they
have to do is sit there and look pretty
um just like us it's like us it's not as
easy as people think it is no and
everyone just wants to hear from us you
know I know you can't just sit here and
look pretty I mean we could and it would
be good it would be gorgeous but it
wouldn't be great no no no no well it's
great because it's Wednesday and we've
got stories we've also got to your
toasters you know some conundrums to
help the girlies through
um we're together yeah we're alive yeah
what else is going right for us today
you got a new couch I got a new couch
this morning it was just delivered I'm
so excited to like go downstairs and
really Tinker with it and make it my own
live with the pillows get it all
decorated my living room is now coming
together most of the pieces have arrived
but I need to like move my TV over and
then play some more things so I'm really
excited Journey big things happening you
chose a big week to come I'm a big girl
so it's only right ain't that the truth
okay watch your mouth when you talk to
me like that okay
sorry I was just like backing up
everything that you say Jackie said kind
of on one this morning like she told me
she like my outfit like I went into
Claudia's room and she was already
complaining about her outfit no I just
said like you know my capsule wardrobe
here is not doing what it needs to be do
to be doing because I I honestly am
spending way more time here than I
thought I ever would I thought I just
like needed the bare minimum like no I
need a full Luke a full wardrobe like
we've been plans this weekend I'm gonna
have to borrow something from you or
Olivia like my my capsule collection
it's not cutting it yeah so I just like
didn't disagree with her she was like
yeah you look like trash that's really
weird I didn't say you look like trash
you just said like you're giving trashy
Vibes that's literally not what I said
I'm not gonna repeat what I said because
it was worse
it's not it was not but some things
could be meant for the private no she
just like entered and was like wow
you're so ugly that's what she said I
would no I'm kidding I'm kidding I can't
with the [__] blasphemy the fallacies
coming out of your mouth she didn't say
that she just said you look wow you're
putting the turd and literia that's what
she said yeah that is what I said let's
get real I'm so like living for our
literia mcclurtia era the way this
nickname has caught on I know I don't
stop talking about it but literally
every message I get is like turd
lettered
um and I hope we never exit this era
like the thing with you is like your
nickname is always In and Out of Africa
and fleeting like some things have
lasted and stood the test of time that's
true like counselor snitch yeah you know
yeah but she didn't see that one coming
no none of us did years and years I hope
La turia is here to stay but you never
know you can't control you don't know
where she'll go from here and that's the
thing about literia she's so mysterious
but I will take your request and I will
file right away and I'll let that info
into my next decision I will
um and I also feel like every time we
podcast together like the next day on
the podcast I say something to this
effect but I have to say it again
I'm not okay
yesterday was the hardest day of my life
every time we podcast together here yeah
because you know taking care of Harry
but yesterday Olivia was just so busy
she had her hands tied she said can I
travel
she had her hands full and she said can
I drop Michaela off and I said of course
like I thought you know
we would lay in bed that's that's the
thing about Michaela she loves to lay in
bed and watch TV she's like my soul
sister but I got like Michaela on crack
yesterday she had just woken up from her
nap and I just watched her playing in
bed she was done with laying in bed and
Olivia said you know you could do
whatever you want with her but she can't
jump around because she got her adenoid
surgery so like her ears are very
sensitive she can't jump around I'm like
great I'm not looking to jump around
anyways what did Michaela want to do
jump the [__] around she wanted to go
outside she wants to jump on the bed
like I needed this [__] to sit down I
was so tired I it was like I had worked
a full day and now I had to work
Michaela hours
when her parents came to pick her up and
have dinner with us like they couldn't
leave fast enough like I needed everyone
to go to sleep I needed to lay in bed I
was not okay like and I understand that
being like a stay-at-home mom is such a
privilege when I tell you it's a
horrendous like I never want to do it
would you rather be a stay-at-home mom
or assemble chairs on the beach
[__] okay so for some backstory since I
feel like I've been said this in a while
people always ask it like it's like a
dinner party question like what's the
job you would least likely want to have
and everyone's like shovel [__] at the
elephant circus
shovel elephant [__] at the circus mine
is 100 I would not want to be like a
Cabana Boy on the beach who like sets up
chairs and umbrellas in the sun
um it's too much physical labor I hate
being outside and like it's so hot all
of my least favorite things like walking
in the sand it's not just like you could
sooner do it at the pool but of course
they're sending out the tension on the
beach walking on the beach is so hard
yeah plus like carrying everything
setting it up that job is the
amalgamation of everything I hate like
being physical being hot being outside
um
so would I rather do that or to me like
a lot of the elements of being a
stay-at-home mom mirror that of being a
commander boy it's kind of like the same
physical Vibe yeah I think I'd rather
still rather be a stay-at-home mom
because I get to be outside no yeah and
there's air conditioning yeah but it's a
really good question yeah drop a comment
you guys what's the job you would least
likely want to have yeah I feel like
people don't think it through because
everyone's always like garbage man it's
like really the garbage truck has air
conditioning no and like the benefits
and the pay yeah you are severely well
taken care of you work for the city you
have great health insurance you have an
aux cord like what's bad you meet lovely
people I think for me and this is really
specific to me and it should be the
answer should be this is other people's
like job and it's like not a bad it's a
great job but for my skill set and my
weaknesses the thing that I would be the
worst at that would like just drain me
would be being a real estate broker and
going around and and talking all and
like wearing heels and like meeting new
people all day and like like just no not
person I'm personable but like you're
just having your social battery small
talk all day long yeah no that's for me
that's not a job I could see you doing
no and like if I showed you the
apartment like here you go take a look
you know it is what it is like I'm not
gonna change your mind no way around
like I know the Sub-Zero fridge and all
the details like
I couldn't I think I could do it I feel
like real estate agency is like a
performance of sorts yes that's true and
I could Dazzle yeah you could you could
I think I could do that I don't know if
I would enjoy it I think it's a lot of
time I'm on my healed feet in the heels
the heels it's not fair
um like when I see those uh selling
Sunset girls I'm like you have my utmost
search bag yeah but I think I could do
it and I'm also like
another thing that is not my skill is
like sales I don't think I would be good
in sales like trying to convince someone
to buy something like I'm very like if
you like it you should get it no end and
if you don't need it you probably
shouldn't no and I think also part of
being a real estate agent is like you
know relying on personal and social
connections like oh do you need a house
let me tell you this or oh I just saw
this great property you might be
interested in it and like for me mixing
work and like my friends kill me like
seriously shoot take me out and shoot me
yeah I hate to be like
to even like seem like I'm trying to
like gain something from a friendship
you know yeah I hate that yeah no you
have to be able to like work your
network yeah your network is your net
worth yeah for me yeah
no but I'm curious you guys um drop a
comment what would be the job any job in
the world that you would not want to
have yeah because it's so Random yeah
it's just based on like
what your weaknesses are and what your
strengths are right and I just feel like
those cliched answers like once you
start thinking about them they're not
that bad like even shoveling [__] at the
circus okay like the ship part isn't
great but the circus is a family did you
see the greatest showman literally and
there's entertainment like I'm sure you
get after hours tickets and like I'm
sure you get free popcorn travel you see
the world yeah it doesn't sound that bad
no it doesn't so I'm just curious what
other people's like death jobs are you
know yeah yeah yeah I'll keep thinking
about it and I'm sure other peoples are
like jobs that I would actually really
like I'm sure for some people like they
could never be a teacher they could not
be around like kids I would love to be a
teacher I think I would be a really good
teacher you know what you always used to
say that and I was like yeah sure
whatever and now seeing you as a mom
like you're such like not the type of
Mom I thought you were gonna be like
you're not that I thought you were gonna
be a bad mom like but you're like above
and beyond like the best mom ever and so
I actually could see you even like with
Kayla like you bring the same energy to
Harry that you bring to Kayla like you
don't like treat Harry better because
he's like technically yours like you
really love kids yeah I do I do and I
didn't see that honestly like I didn't
used to say like I want to be a teacher
I'm like okay pray for the camera for
the kids like like no I didn't see it at
all yeah but I see it now yeah so
everyone always asks like if you were in
a podcast or what would you do and
unfortunately I think I would like
probably still be in some sort of like
social media marketing and not know how
to break out of it yeah but what I
should have been doing is being a
teacher even if I was just like a
substitute teacher substitute to the
best yeah Bad Teacher Holly Holiday from
Glee yeah I think if I wasn't doing this
I always say like I would be a
veterinarian for literally never a
veterinarian for one like I would be a
private client concierge vet only to
Theo's study medicine so that you could
cure him a hundred percent I don't know
I really don't know what I would do like
I know that I would probably just like
you have a job like in marketing or
media because that's like what I studied
in college that's like what we know but
that's not what we should be doing no
I should be a pop star like for real
yeah that's my dream I guess that's
technically what you're doing now like
not really as close to it as you can
make yourself get I always say like when
I am you know about to go on stage at
Madison Square Garden like I'm so
honored and humbled to be there but like
I wish it was for singing like I and I
love doing comedy okay what if like
whenever you get your biggest venue
whatever that's gonna be next like it's
gonna be for your tour but what if you
just like came out backup dancers no and
like yeah just did a concert I think I
think everyone would be really
understanding I think at first it would
be confused and then like once I saw the
talent and the passion did we get on
board they would be understanding like
okay we know McLaren she's living her
dream like we love that right we'll take
this L for her yeah yeah I think we'll
catch the special online yeah I think
they'd be understanding too yeah think
about it but that is like my absolute
dream because people always like you
must be living your dream and I totally
am but like I do feel like part of me is
like missing out like on I all I ever
wanted to be was a pop star I feel like
maybe you should work it into every set
like an intermission or something yeah
where you just get to live out your
dream for a few minutes or like I'll end
the show because I want it to be like
perfect I want the show to be perfect
and then I'll come back and be like by
the way you guys can leave but like I am
going to do another 30 minutes just
singing but this is not mandatory feel
free to leave feel free to go get a
drink I think they'll stay
maybe not the husbands
but they need to drive home so true that
way that's they'll wait in the car yeah
listen to the toes
um so we've got a great show today uh I
don't have anything really else oh I'm
watching Jenny and Georgia and you know
people are like begging me to wreak
habit they're like I saw most common
yeah I did nagging like pleading Claudia
please I'm only on like episode four or
five and like it's not really like a
substantial show that you can recap like
where you can have intellectual
conversations about it it is so bad but
it's like incredible I love Georgia
can't with Jenny I think that's the
point like she's like this angsty teen
who's just being so so dumb like
and George was like this you know teen
mom who like you know hustles hard and I
just I love Georgia and I just want
Jenny to be nice to her mom I just it's
basically a TV show about like a kid
who's mean to their mom and I I feel
like I saw enough of that growing up I
hate people who are rude to their
parents and it's definitely triggering
me hmm yeah but I do think you would
like it that's what Olivia said Olivia
watches it too I think you would like it
I don't know if if I have it in me to
give it a chance so you know for you
like whenever you see that guy
what's his name Richard from
the ball type yeah that actor you know
when you see him in like a Hallmark
movie or a TV show like you know it's
going to be your type of show yeah I
realized last night I have one of those
who the character
um who plays Jason Street in Friday
Night Lights yeah he's in Heart of Dixie
he's also he's the mayor on this show I
know if he's in a show or a movie I'm
going to like it yeah that's good and
it's so funny I don't know why like I
have this like weird connection to him
like maybe because I was really moved by
his story when I saw him in Friday Night
Lights as a young girl but um whenever
I'm reading a book I always find a
character who I imagine as him he was in
something else recently like something
real also the [__] is his name yeah I'm
on my Jason Street actor
his name is Scott Porter oh that sounds
right and he is in
everything part of Dixie Friday Night
Lights Jenny in Georgia but there's
something
else oh he was in why women kill we
loved that show I did love that show who
was he season one or two
that is so weird I loved that show
hold on let me think there was a couple
in the 50s
and then Lucy Liu and like the modern
day couple it must have been a different
season because I didn't think it might
have been season two which was really
terrible I didn't finish it it was
really really bad let me look for a
picture oh oh he was married to that
girl from America's Next Top Model and
they murdered him spoiler alert
remember her oh he was the abusive yeah
my bad husband he was bad that was kind
of like a departure for him too
yeah because he's only like he must have
like an agent who specializes in trash
whatever that agency is where you'd like
to get a job I need to get signed that's
your dream job that's my dream job is to
like be in like Hallmark
except like again know thyself in your
skill set like I would not be good as an
actor as an actress what do you mean I'm
not a good actress really yeah don't say
that I hate to say it and I know that
the craft doesn't require much it
doesn't but I'm not good I think I could
be like an incredible actress I think
you could too because you're very
dramatic like I'm not a good actress and
I'm comfortable saying that no but I
feel like you like you and I will go
somewhere and we'll like be with people
or whatever and we'll get in the car and
I'll be like I [__] hated that and
you'll be like really what like I
thought you were having a good time like
I think I'm a good actor like in
everyday life yeah
like Ben is always like we're getting
the karma like [__] like let's get home
he's like I thought you were having a
good time yeah that like even my own
family believes me
yeah no I think they've got the skill
set for it I just I feel like I could I
think I can act like an everyday life
you know when I need to behave uh but
when it's intentional and like dramatic
like I have nothing to give I mean
actors are just they're just liars yeah
and no one's not a liar no I am I liked
you yesterday you did
I asked her if she she's getting in my
bed like while I was out she just wanted
to like relax in my bed because her room
was occupied and I asked it just was
like did you shower last night she was
like no I was like oh but you bathed and
she was like yeah I wasn't expecting the
follow-up question at first I was going
to tell the truth you were like did you
shower I was like no like I wasn't even
smelly or sweaty and like I was fine and
Jackie was like
I guess to Jackie the concept of me
showering was so inconceivable she just
assumed that I bathed yeah because my
room has a tub we're talking about how
you were excited to take a bath at night
so Jack was like oh so you babes I was
like oh yeah so I just went along with
the lie and then I told her a few hours
later that I lied I just after she had
been in my bed and I'm not gonna lie
like she was upset there no I I just
don't like that you lied to me I wasn't
planning on lying but you kind of like
cornered me with the with this follow-up
question I did not like so what I didn't
bathe like who cares I'm literally no
one but you made it a big deal by lying
about it right isn't that what you
always say
it's not the crime it's the cover-up
that is what I always say I really
believe that too I just felt like it was
truly a harmless little white lie yeah
except like and not in a negative way
but maybe it's just because like you're
a different person when I got into my
bed last night like oh shut up seriously
shut the [__] up your bed was fine I
laid on top of the covers in my clean
pajamas I don't even start like don't
[__] start protective like I would
have known someone else's in my bed that
day you're such a little
like don't even lie to me like that
don't I literally I did have the thought
of myself it's not this isn't a lie that
it might have just been like you were
just saying you were just saying that
two minutes ago that you don't lie so
don't start now I don't know don't
[__] start now you're such a liar I
literally had the thought when I put my
head my pillow I was like someone else
was in here today well I guess there's
two Liars on set today Bryson Trice rise
and dress these boys lie through their
teeth oh Mom I didn't have dinner yet
yeah two dinner Bryce actually you know
Bryce did yesterday
um kind of chug my diet coke was he up
all night with the Zoomies I couldn't
believe you drank myself all night
tending to his mother because I had a
migraine and he was like mama can I get
you a cold compress Mama do you want
your eye massager I was like yes Bryce
please and Mama
um Bruno lives in the 1930s yeah my
whole household does we have my mom papa
totally mama papa I have Papa
oh yeah yeah papa yeah you have pop it's
funny how like intonation is everything
you know it really is
um so let's get you because we kind of
got a big show lots of stories some
drums and then to your toasters which
I'm excited about so without further Ado
About the Doos here are the past five
stories that you need to know and I'm so
excited because we have a brand new
sponsor today well that's very near and
dear to our labias it is European Wax
Center sponsoring today's episode
Breakaway from the winter Blues with a
wax from the experts book a service
today at European Wax Center dot at
European Wax Center period all it takes
period period all it takes is 15 minutes
whether you're jet setting or just
staying at home get the quick refresh
you deserve in 15 minutes or less and
extend your smooth at home with our post
wax phase each one is designed to
complement your wax and maintain silky
smooth skin all winter long so whether
you're like a regular waxer or you want
to get into it I feel like Jackie's been
waxing for so long and I've only
recently started to get into waxing
because it's obviously the better choice
for hair removal and I was like kind of
nervous about it Margot is obsessed with
European Wax Center I know you are too
so um Margo actually took me I got my
armpits and my upper lip which is uh
sadly a necessity and she took me to her
favorite early at European Wax Center
and I have to say it was such a pleasant
experience it's really not so bad and
they make it fun they have a great
playlist going like a lot of Kelly
Clarkson everybody who works there is so
nice you get caught up in the convo and
the wax is over I've been going to
European Wax Center for years I go to a
European Wax Center down here and it's
nice like whether you're traveling or
you've moved like it's a name that you
can trust because you don't want to let
a lot of people in in to those of your
wax them no it's true they're really and
especially for me in the city there's so
many convenient locations when we went
um to get our first manicures together
when you moved down here there was a
European wax center right next to the
nail place
um and they do everything from browse to
toes European Wax Center specializes in
all kinds of smooth because smooth is
what they do and what's better than a
smooth escape a free one so your first
one is on European Wax Center get your
first wax free and you're at European
Wax Center
so experience a new state of smooth at
European Wax Center make your resume
reservation today your first wax is free
beat the winter Blues with the wax from
the experts keeping you silky smooth all
season long with 15 minutes 15 minute
appointments exclusive Comfort wax and
an array of post-wax products beating
the winter Blues is smoother than ever
before want to give it a try your first
wax is on the house get your first wax
Fray at European Wax Center today's
episode is all set free I did say free
she said free today's episode is also
brought to you by Clinique many things
in life can dehydrate your skin
including weather pollution blue light
time spent in the sun mask wearing air
traveling and air conditioning fight
back against life's daily dehydrators
with Clinique Moisture Surge 100 hour
this supercharged gel cream hydrator
delivers 100 hours of hydration for
plump glowing skin even after washing
your face Auto replenishing technology
helps skin create its own internal water
source delivering continuous oil-free
and non-greasy radiant hydration after
one week 99 percent of women say that
their skin it leaves their skin feeling
deeply hydrated so Clinique is a brand
that you can certainly trust and this
time of year I feel like everyone's skin
is getting like dry and Flaky and just
like kind of crusty and gross
um so turn to the experts at Clinique
the oil-free gel cream moisturizer with
aloe bioforamine and ha complex
penetrates deep into the Skin's surface
for 100 hours of stabilizing hydration
plus the auto replenishing technology
helps skin create its own internal water
source to continually rehydrate itself
then lock in moisture and your skin will
feel soothed with hydration in three
seconds and it keeps on glowing so um
I've used this product after one
application I saw an immediate boost in
hydration and just My overall skin
radiance
my dehydrated skin was smoothed and
comforted with a nourishing hydration
that lasts I feel like sometimes you'll
put on a product and it'll just like go
away after a few minutes but this
product from Clinique like is
continually hydrating your skin
throughout the day and you'll notice
like that glow in that Radiance
um all day long and then in four weeks
women saw 37 Improvement in Skin Barrier
strength more balanced skin microbiome
and a visible Improvement in the
appearance appearance in Fine Dry lines
which can be like really gross and
crusty this time of year
so you'll apply it twice daily in the
morning and at night on Clean Skin you
can use it alone or under makeup on dry
spots as a five minute mask as a cuticle
treatment as a frizz fighter whatever it
is whatever issue you're having this
product will work for you just one use
and you'll see an improvement in skin
Radiance so shop the Clinique Moisture
Surge 100 hour this Valentine's Day for
20 off when you go to clinique.com the
discount is valid through Valentine's
Day December not December February 14th
so shop Clinique Moisture Surge 100
hours Valentine's Day and for 20 off go
to clinique.com the discount is valid
through Valentine's Day Ty yet welks
first story Little World Tour news
Beyonce announces Renaissance world tour
dates for summer 2023
the Superstar performer announced her
highly anticipated Renaissance World
Tour on Wednesday Beyonce will kick off
the U.S leg on July 12th in Philadelphia
with subsequent stops in cities
including Chicago New York City Boston
Atlanta Miami Las Vegas Los Angeles
Houston and New Orleans among others so
this is very exciting I think it's been
a while since Beyonce has been on tour
and now she's doing it there's a lot of
world tours going on I feel like there
are a lot of world tours going on and I
wonder if they have to like navigate
around each other like do you think
Beyonce like waited a little bit because
it's summer 2023 it's like kind of when
Taylor starts like do you think she had
to
like not accommodate but like you know
she didn't wanna
do it too close to Taylor and like have
to compete to be honest no no
I don't what about Madonna
no different demographic yeah yeah
I also I like that I like this time
frame that she announced like it's it's
not February and we can get excited for
summer 23 like that's a good amount of
leeway I also think like only really
Beyonce could do that because like you
have to know for sure like stadiums like
most people play stadiums they don't
sell out immediately like a couple
people do but you need like a decent
amount of time to lead up to the shows
in order to sell like 90 of the seats
out but I feel like Beyonce's like one
of the only people who could do it like
literally four months before yeah it's
like not that long but Taylor sold out
everything right because you guys
couldn't get tickets yeah Taylor's like
a Beyonce as well yes yes yes yeah
because we couldn't get tickets yeah rub
it in yeah so what's going on with your
tickets um I just can't explain like how
relaxed I am that's so good like I have
no tickets I have no prospects I'm 27
I've no money and no prospects but I
just know I'm gonna be there yeah
I can't like explain how I'm not
concerned I'm not concerned for you like
I'm so happy to be there
I'm feeling very calm you are a beacon
of calmness calmness is my superpower
that is not true that is a lie a lie a
big lie I would say what's your
superpower probably like my looks yeah
no actually what's my superpower my
personality like that's so something an
ugly person would say but like
it is like it is I'm sorry I think
people like you know
sometimes think they might not like me
or like you know and then like you can
turn them I really like with your powers
I'm a dazzler I really am yeah
and I just happen to be beautiful which
is so unfair but um no that's definitely
that's what's on the inside that counts
another thing that you would say to an
ugly person wow I'm just feeling like
really gorgeous today
um no my personality what would you say
is your superpower
oh
I would say actually calmness yeah I
would say Communists among like you're
so level-headed like you never get like
Hasty you know like what do they say
about decisions in haste like you've
never made one of those when I'm I make
one once a day yeah
yeah no I would take my my calmness and
just like my
level headedness that was a good word
yeah
um so Beyonce is going on tour I feel
like everyone's I feel like everyone's
gonna be going like so many concerts
this summer that's so fun I love that
for us yeah and I do think normally like
we would not like be experiencing a
Taylor torn a Beyonce tour like in the
same few months years to make up for
right years were taken off of our lives
and they must be added back quite
literally quite literally speaking of
concerts there's also been some Buzz
that Harry Styles have got like a really
big offer to do a Vegas residency
oh my God I mean that's a great idea
he'll be amazing and he's so Vegas but
he's so Vegas like take a break I know I
do think conceptually it's like a good
idea for him and his brand especially
because he kind of like does residencies
yeah he does like a couple weeks in New
York a couple weeks in La
um but my God yeah he did like take like
a month off
and now he's back at the Forum but it's
not even about taking time off it's
about like scheduling your schedule to
be Humane yeah
no I agree like with days off in between
I know it's like sad he needs to calm
down yeah
um but I do think he would probably put
on like an amazing show I think I would
go see that yeah I could go for a trip
to Vegas me too we need to see Adele and
we need to see Carrie Underwood oh when
does she start she's go she's on right
because Rach won oh did she yeah that
would be a good one too the country
women do a good Vegas residency I think
Miranda Lambert just wrapped one up too
they're like it's so Vegas also it's
like diamond and denims you know it must
be fun to live in Vegas and like you
have every concert that you could just
go to yeah I thought you were gonna say
it must be fun for like Carrie Underwood
to live in Vegas for a few months and I
actually don't think it is no and I
don't think that they do no yeah that
sounds like Adele says on the weekends I
think she probably goes back to LA on
Monday morning yeah I I really do want
to see Adele what's crazy is like the
ticket prices have not come down it
looks amazing it looks amazing video I
see like I watch the whole thing and I'm
glad that I did me too I do want to say
it doesn't look like the production is
so wild they couldn't have gotten it
right the first time but I've moved on
from that I'm just still like a little
suspicious
um and I really do want to see it like
especially when she goes into the
audience I'm like a little annoyed not
that I have any plans to go I'm annoyed
like when she goes into the audience
which is like kind of like the worst
part of a concert like everyone has to
turn around like you can't even see the
person
um it's during my favorite song she goes
in when we when we were young yeah
not to complain about a show I probably
won't say yeah maybe you should tell her
no maybe she'll hear this
um anyways Beyonce I'm excited for
everyone who's gonna go but I feel like
it's not enough shows and there's gonna
be like a Calamity trying to get tickets
well we'll have to see how Ticketmaster
handles you know they have their hearing
yeah and it was like all the politicians
at first I thought it was funny and like
no not for one second did I think it was
fine no then I was like okay these
people are like trying to be viral this
is like giving cringe like the second
before like everyone said like all these
people in Congress really like talking
to Ticketmaster and like then speaking
in Taylor Swift lyrics and it was like
obviously one person did it and then the
next person and the next person and it
was so cringe it would look at their
notes and be like
Ticketmaster
you're a nightmare
dress like a Daydream Ticketmaster now
we have bad blood Ticketmaster you
should say to yourself it's me
hi
I'm the problem it's me like cringe
Beyond it was cringe Beyond yeah at
first I was here for it and then like
the long the more the more people I saw
doing it and each one got worse and
worse I thought this is what's wrong
with our country and why you know eggs
are eight dollars this is what's wrong
with our country
you ever just like
forget how to drink and you're suddenly
soaked are you so I'm covered in pellet
groin because you didn't put your mouth
on it I didn't no oh my God it's
everywhere
whatever
are you ready for our next story I took
that shower you finally wanted me to
take are you ready for our next story
yeah Tom Brady says he's retiring for
good after 23 seasons in an emotional
video so Tom baby Brady put out a video
this morning saying give them a chance
to make fun of himself yeah he said I'm
retiring for good I know the process was
a pretty big deal last time so when I
woke up this morning I figured I'd just
press record and let you guys know first
he said press record he oh yeah he did
say press record it won't be long they
just spelled it wrong on People magazine
it won't be long-winded you only get one
super emotional retirement thank you and
I used mine up last year so I really
thank you guys so much he said to every
single one of you for supporting me my
family my friends my teammates my
competitors I could go on forever
there's too many thank you guys for
allowing me to live my absolute dream I
wouldn't change a thing love you all
well you should I just feel like nothing
is a little bit of a lie yeah especially
not even because that he like didn't do
great this season he lost his family he
lost his like you know if he had just
retired when he said that he would he
would still be married to Giselle
according to
sources right
um like whatever like it's way it's
crazy how like he is the goat and like I
feel like nobody cares like it's so it's
almost played out at this point at least
he knows he's not trying to like make a
meal of it he's just like no it was a
self-aware statement and for that we're
extremely grateful because like we're
all looking at him side eye though this
time I was a little bummed because there
were rumors he might be going to the
49ers and they actually could really use
him and he could use them like I guess
they need a strong QB they have
everything I think his time is up
they have everything else really strong
I know and he's from the Bay Area well
that's true
um I do Wonder like what's on his mind
like is he lit I could see like
everything we have heard about like the
whole Giselle thing being a lie but like
if it's true this has to be a person
like living with deep regret yes but
like I think that it it's more than just
like one decision for him to go back to
football that would like end his very
long marriage you know because if they
were otherwise so happy Yeah there has
to be something else then they would
have made it work so I just I think it
was they were at the end of their Road
and that was the last straw but if it
wasn't that there would have been a
different straw are you at the end of
your road or the end of your rope
I think you could be at both I think
it's at the end of I mean you could be I
feel like end of your rope is a little
like morbid like giving like suicidal
Vibes yes the vibe I'm getting rope is
definitely so I I'm gonna I'm Gonna
Change it to Road did you see Kylie
wearing that necklace yeah that was the
news that was [__] weird yeah I'm all
about like you know making a statement
with your art but like it's [__]
weird yeah that she's just getting like
kind of weirder and weirder darker
and more Twisted more twisted and like
you sing further away from like what
regular people want to wear yeah totally
so
um for that reason I stay in my
sweatshirt yeah for that reason I'll say
in this outfit that you didn't like
that's not what I said you didn't like
it first that's not what I said I'm
insane I like it
um I'm happy for Tom you know I hope he
enjoys his retirement whatever he does
his businesses gets into sportcasting
um but I had I have like so many like
like I'm curious you know like about
what he's really feeling at this time
because I could see a world in which
like he kind of like looked like
depressed in that video
yeah and I don't know if it was just
because like you know he's ending his
career or because like he kind of went
out like a loser like I'm retiring never
mind yeah but like you have to remember
he's not a loser like if he's ever
feeling that way he can look at his six
Super Bowl rings and feel better yeah
so did he win a Super Bowl
since leaving the Patriots Yeah I think
the Bucks won once and then he retired
I I don't know I I feel like he retired
before he went to the Box me too I think
he won with the Patriots retired
came back one with the Bucks and then
lost twice the once once twice yeah okay
so it's not like that loser but it's not
great yeah
are you ready for our next story which
is really kind of crazy kind of crazy
so Nicola peltz's snippy text blasting
her wedding planner's mistakes have been
shown in a lawsuit yes because nichola's
Dad is suing this wedding planning Duo
for not giving back a deposit that he
deposited even though they didn't mind
up working with them so according to the
Daily Mail uh Nicholas father filed a
lawsuit against wedding planners Nicole
bragan and Ariana
geraldba for refusing to give back the
159 000 deposit he gave them in the
lawsuit he's claiming that he and his
wife hired them in March 2022 through
their firm plan design events after
partying leaves with their first wedding
planner the pelts has hired the duo six
weeks before the star-studded nuptials
were to take place however after only
nine days on the job the duo decided not
to move forward with Nicola and Brooklyn
because they could not handle the
couple's guest list which included more
than 500 people uh per the Daily Mail
the lawsuit reads the celebrity of the
wedding couple combined with the
anticipated attendance of many
high-profile guests required that the
wedding planner had the expertise in
Staffing to plan corn need and execute a
wedding event of the expected caliber
and complexity yeah like not just any
old wedding planner could execute this I
heard that this was like there there
they went through like three or four
people until they found the right one
this being one of them yeah this was
number two and the lawsuit is because
they didn't get their deposit back but
the lawsuit included some text messages
yeah Nicola had allegedly sent the
wedding planners in the lawsuit
including one where the actress said she
was quote tired of fixing their mistakes
after they said Lewis Hamilton RSVP yes
although he told the couple he could not
attend the wedding so she texted them
Lewis Hamilton did not RSVP so explain
why his name's on the list please
she said we spoke to him he can't come
so explain why you said he rsvp'd yes
the wedding planner said she tried to
explain that she needed more time to get
familiar with the app that the virtual
guest list was on she said I need time
to do this I'm going to take a moment to
learn the app and send you the
information I hate looking like a fool
but I hate the most not giving you what
you need ASAP I will be back soon Nicola
who was seemingly upset allegedly
replied that's not true he didn't RSVP
at all
Nicholas dad also claimed in the lawsuit
that the wedding planners had a drinking
problem and oh because they sent a text
to Nichola saying
um
that one of them said going for a
tequila before her headache was about to
explode to which Nicola replied yes
Queen so I guess like that's okay that's
traumatic Mr Peltz yeah so he's also
reported suing for the legal fees
um I don't know it kind of sounds like
they were pretty far into the planning
process with these planners because they
were accepting RSVPs so they deserve to
be paid for something
yeah but to be paid versus like the
deposit yeah I don't know what this
money is like specifically for I've
never heard of a wedding planner taking
a deposit they get a fee yeah
I don't know and then they they wound up
hiring a different wedding planner with
how much time to spare like this was
already six weeks out like right how
many weeks did they work for them a week
two weeks no it has I feel like they
probably worked with them for a decent
amount of time
if they were already in the collecting
RSVP stage that's that's six to eight
weeks no but they hired them at six
weeks out they had a different wedding
planner before Oh you know that for sure
yeah that's okay
they hired them with six weeks till the
wedding got it okay so no and then they
didn't go with them and there's a
different wedding planner that's [__]
crazy by the way I thought all of this
was like you know one year out
starting to plan going through a few
planners and then ending with one not
changing planners six weeks before
that's crazy yeah
and I don't know I don't really under
maybe this is like a mega mega rich
person thing but I'd never heard of a
planner taking a deposit
yeah
so that's why he wants his money back
yeah so I wonder I wonder who's like
gonna win like who's entitled to them
like her dad is like a billionaire I
know I don't think it's like a bad look
no I don't think he would go for a
lawsuit that wasn't uh a win for him
right
um because it is a bad look if if the
law isn't on his side yeah that's true
Crystal [__] clear yeah that's true
it's just like so awkward like having
your text messages being leaked so
awkward I actually don't think that
they're that bad considering like it
could have been worse heard about her
but also the dad put hers in so like
maybe there were others yeah he like
they'll add them but um I'm sorry that's
like so dramatic she's just like a
little snippy about Lewis Hamilton like
why is he on here he told us he wasn't
coming no but like so dramatic to like
submit a text message where she says she
needs a drink because it was like a
special a stressful day she has a
drinking problem calm down but like at
least we could see Nicola was a nice
Ventura yes Queen yeah because I could
see Nicola being like such a [__] so
scary like she's like just thinking how
do you mean as a bride right before her
wedding like how do you not like when
you grow up like her family people don't
even think understand like they're like
the top one percent of the one percent
like they're like next level Rich she's
so gorgeous she's in Hollywood like how
could you not be like a French [__]
I just don't know how you couldn't not
be like the most nasty [__] alive I
mean there's a way where you're just
like so grateful for your Bountiful
Blessing I can tell you it wouldn't be
me like if I was so perfect and like
literally came from like billionaire
billionaire billionaire family became
like a Starlet was perfect looking like
you could not catch me being nice to a
single human being like you I wouldn't
even pretend I know you you wouldn't
even look at me well actually if you're
still my sister that means you're also
like a billionaire I think she loves her
little sis okay is she always posting
her sis I don't know I feel like she is
like I just it's so important to know
thyself yeah and I just know I would be
worse than Nicola like I just know it
yeah especially six weeks out she's
having wedding drama I should have
called Birch like yeah they would it
just also never it's so interesting like
really
maybe a wedding of this magnitude
happens like in this country like three
times a year who is like because this is
bigger than like Kardashian even I feel
like who's the mini wife Mindy White's
like I feel like someone bigger like
who's bigger than Mindy Weiss
I don't know but they it happens it
exists all the time but I'm just like
who is it not every day who is it I
don't know it's anyone's job for the
taking speaking of 30 they should have
hired Gertie she's in Miami I don't
think so
um
So Random I don't know what just
reminded me of this but
um yesterday we were talking about how
like Orlando Bloom and Katy Perry I mean
Miranda Kern Katy Perry were at that
event together so Miranda Kerr posted a
tick tock it was so cute of her like
dancing with Katy Perry and being like
when you love your son's stepmom so much
like obsessed obsessed I love that I
feel like a lot of people didn't even
realize that like
there was a kid yeah yeah they're like
kind of they're like really private
actually with their kids like as they
should be
um and now I think I'm like becoming
obsessed like I need to see I need to
see more step co-parenting content yeah
they should do an episode of like a
podcast blending yeah they should they
should start a blended podcast yeah
where they like bring on parents who
having a hard time co-parenting and they
just kind of ameliorate the situation
immediately yeah which actually is a
great segue into our next story because
they could become the new Dr Phil with
that oh and is it the new story that
that that's brought to you by kids is
there a coincidence like is that is that
the one that's the one all right you
guys today's episode is brought to you
by kids 2023 is the year of good we're
feeling good we're doing good and we're
being good to ourselves Kitsch made
makes feeling good simple with luxurious
game changing Essentials that beauty
enthusiasts swear by and they say that
hair care is a new skincare but there's
one brand that is taken into the next
level with a cult-like following kitch
has created game changing Essentials
that beauty enthusiasts are swearing by
like from satin pillowcases to
time-saving towels they know hair care
doesn't stop in the shower so whatever
your budget whatever your skin type or
your hair type kitchen believes that you
deserve little indulgences at an
affordable price morning noon and night
they were started in 2010 by selling
hair ties door-to-door they just started
hustling and all they had was a dream
and now they are sold in over 20 000
retail locations so their best sellers
include a lot of favorites here from
Jackie and I the satin pillowcases
um they also make satin eye masks and
caps the satin is vegan and cruelty free
they are so great for your hair and for
your skin while you sleep
um if you wake up with like a Rat's Nest
and you find yourself having to re-give
yourself a blowout every morning which
was me a few months ago starts sleeping
with a satin pillowcase or wearing a
satin cap on your head it will make the
biggest difference also
um it's great for your skin like if you
wake up with lines on your face that can
cause like aging and wrinkles and satin
pillowcases are just like an all-around
great thing to have there's no reason
you shouldn't
um they also have shampoo and
conditioner bars which are part of
bottle-free beauty they also offer a
heatless satin curling roller so you can
say goodbye to heat damage
um it's amazing to get like curls and
blowouts at a fraction of the price it's
literally 18
um so right now kitch is offering you 30
off your entire order at mykitch.com
toast that's 30 off anything and
everything at my kitchen
toast that's my kitch.com toast for 30
off your order thank you turdy
you're welcome
next story Dr Phil's talk show will end
after 21 Seasons he said I'm moving on
from daytime the long running daytime
talk show hosted by Dr Phil McGraw will
wrap after its current
2022-2023 season which is the 21st Dr
Phil is ending his time with the show
after signing his most recent contract
with CBS Media Ventures which was good
for five years in 2018 the syndication
company is expected to give networks the
option to run previously taped episodes
for the forthcoming 2023-24 season he
said in a statement to people I've been
blessed with over 25 wonderful years in
daytime television with this show we
have helped thousands of guests and
millions of viewers through everything
from addiction and marriage to mental
wellness and raising children this has
been an incredible chapter of my life
and career but while I'm moving on from
daytime there is so much more I wish to
do CBS Media Ventures said that Dr Phil
will soon share details on a strategic
Prime Time partnership that will help
him increase his impact on television
and viewers
I feel like this timing is really good
because it's only a matter of time
before Dr Phil gets canceled like there
was like a small movement led by
Danielle bregoli a few years ago and
like it had a little bit of traction
because I think a lot of the facilities
that his production company would like
send troubled teens to was like are some
of those problematic places like Provo
Canyon that Paris Hilton went to
um and you know what he's gotten he's
gotten through 25 years relatively
unscathed and I think in order to
protect his legacy this is the absolute
best thing that he should do it's it's
literally it's a ticking Time Bomb yeah
I don't know if the culture can handle
Dr Phil for much longer no because
doctor feels very much like the tough
love yeah and he like what I think what
a lot of what he used to do like would
not fly today no no so unless he wants
to and I don't think that he should
change no his way or his format but you
know the world has changed yeah and his
time is up his time is up it's also
worth noting that daytime television is
changing like Wendy Williams Show Ellen
Degeneres shows the real like they're
all going I think that this is an
inflection point for daytime
um will it change beyond recognition
where it's to the point where like there
are really none of those shows or it's
like we're just doing Kelly and Drew and
like you know j-hud these types of
really light bright shows that are like
yeah not gonna solve The World's
problems right no you're right we're
definitely moving in that direction like
it's more of like the Ellen Vibe than
the Dr Phil Dr Oz like kind of scary I
feel like sometimes that content's like
fear-mongering like what's in your
Morning cereal cancer you know like and
like um Dr Drew like things like that
the doctors that joke what about Jerry
Springer like right like quaking Maury's
ending right yeah
Steve Wilkos like it's I think we're
I think like our kids will not be
watching you know when they're homesick
from school they'll be watching Kelly
Clarkson and you know what they'll be
better off for it yeah no they could
have I feel like when you're homesick
from school and then you're watching
like you know Jerry Springer and you see
like some someone in Dire Straits it's
like you know what I'll go to school
tomorrow it's true we're scaring the
kids straight while they're sick instead
they'll be singing like
sometimes in the middle of the night I
can feel you again
I just miss you and I just wish you were
a better man you know you'll go in there
supposed to be sick and so they've got
the karaoke machine out love that for
them sorry the karaoke machine Kelly
okay
um but now it's like what's next for Dr
Phil and it says he's obviously working
on some big probably more like
um high level like production or
development thing with CBS and I really
feel like you should give his time slot
to Morgan Stewart
yeah like he should make his next phase
in life like making Morgan Stewart the
next Dr Phil but like of her genre yeah
he must see the talent that's you know
the mother of his grandchildren you know
his daughter-in-law he must see it they
should host a show together and like
maybe like she could bring you down be
that foil where it's like
Phil we don't sing
no I love that format it's like and it
would be bringing like old and young
Generations together I'd bought I'd be
watching in a second on a dime I would
be watching that it's something to think
about he says a podcast that's really
popular he does like more mental health
stuff
um I don't think this is the last of Dr
Phil but I do think in this kind of
anti-weighted format it's not it's not
going to make it's not going to cut it
anymore
yeah but I feel he has so many like fans
and I don't think that's why he's really
leaving like I just do think that
daytime is changing you know and he's
probably over it like doing the same
thing every day for 25 years yeah it's
like he could if he wanted to retire
yeah oh he's so rich yeah he's fine so
we'll see what's next yeah but the end
of an era truly yeah are you ready for
our fifth and final story yeah Britney
Spears is accusing Melissa Milano of
bullying for questioning her well-being
Alyssa Milano Alyssa Milano she said
Melissa Milano I'm like the tick tocker
Melissa Medrano literally no I didn't
you literally said Melissa but okay okay
robust Gaslight repeat you are you you
roll the tapes good because we have all
the tapes because we have them hopefully
today's files don't mysteriously
disappear
uh so Alyssa Milano tweeted someone
please go check on Britney Spears you
know that's what people say these days
yeah I just want to say like before I
give my opinions I'm definitely biased
because I find them Alyssa Milano to be
like one of the most annoying [__] on
the planet continue and so Brittany
posted that to her Instagram story and
said it saddens me to see things about
me from people who don't know me this
definitely feels like a form of bullying
bullying ladies we are supposed to be
rooting for one another not pulling one
another down
you know I might have to understand what
I said I think that might be with Alyssa
Milano on this one because you know what
like it's not bullying it must be tough
for Brittany to see that like Britney is
not okay we all know that I know but I
feel like this is what we're we've
always been saying it's like we you
don't need to check on Brittany like
this is Brittany Ryan this is the
Britney that we freed like and I think
that the situation that she was in was
extremely extreme but at one point like
she was
when like this all started because like
I think that she's not like
what you would consider
normal normal yeah she has her quirks
about her and that doesn't mean that she
has to live her life like a prisoner
though so thus she is free right but
like she's gonna Britney's gonna be
Brittany and he's gonna be a little
weird and she doesn't need anyone to
check in on her no also I just feel like
Alyssa Monash in mind her own business
you know like there's six things things
out there about like her husband like
just stop oh I don't even know there's
stuff out there so just like why don't
you mind your own business and like you
know those in Glass Houses she had said
recently Brittany nope I'm not having a
breakdown I am who I am and moving
forward in my life I've never felt
better that's literally what I think she
is who she is and she's moving forward
in her life I know who she is which is a
person that like you Pro you might not
have thought that she was but she is or
like
I think like two things can be true like
she can be happy but also deeply unwell
do you know what I mean yeah and she
could be unwell but not need to be in a
conservatorship on lithium like writing
every day not being able to accept her
own money having an IED place in her
when she wants kids and not being able
to marry her husband like
she deserves her Freedom yeah and just
because she like dances in here it's not
like what you would post on social media
and and the thing is I don't even like
look at any of it anymore because it is
out there yeah and the girl is free and
she deserves her freedom but it's it's
not you know
it's not the usual celebrity curated
content well it's also important to
remember like not only is Brittany
obviously going through stuff so her
social media is weird
she's also a 40 year old mom like she's
chewy like that is also her aesthetic
like I feel like people are always like
because we expect you know like every
celebrity no matter how old they are has
like some you know 25 year old intern
helping with their social that like it
always comes off like cool like they
know the trends but like Britney is
literally 40 she's a mom of two like
that is kind of the vibe for people that
age like that's what they post maybe not
the dancing but like the quote cards and
like the weird captions yeah I feel like
there was other stuff recently that was
more concerning but it's like she's
working through all of her Newfound
freedom and she's doing it in front of
everyone and that is her right like and
it's gonna be real human being and it's
gonna be ugly and so I don't know that
she needs to be checked on all the time
I think being checked on is what got her
into a situation that was really bad
she's not hurting anyone it doesn't seem
to be that she's hurting herself let the
girl live and be [__] weird
foreign
stop saying and everyone thinks they're
being so like helpful helpful and
magnanimous let's check on Brittany I'm
read about Brittany no she's so very
happy and that mentality this just
happened last week like we need to check
your company like people like
concerned fans like call the cops and
the cops show up at our house in the
middle of the night and like it freaks
her out so it's like we can be concerned
but like there has to be a line please
it's so important for everyone in the
world who cares about Brittany to
remember you don't know Brittany so just
like don't call the cops to her house
like you don't this is still a stranger
to you you don't really know none of us
really know what's going on and we don't
know what she's really like yeah but
hopefully she has a few good people
around her who know what she is really
like and and so know what to look out
for if something is wrong yeah agreed
um
it's been so nice to have the boys back
like Theo's been such a [__] angel
this whole time yeah so was try sand and
now he wants to explore which is his
right
to do his duty he's gonna explore his
duty that's for sure it's pretty damn
sure
um and that's our show oh no it's not
sorry not I was wondering you know me
I'm like not okay today
I mean same let me pull up the deer
touristers for you so it's Wednesday
which means Our advice segment our
favorite day of the week is dear
toasters if you want to email us get
some advice from your favorite girl
these email dear toasters gmail.com and
we will do our best to get your quandary
on air
um we've got some good submissions today
are you ready
ready hey girlie turlies my husband
brings me home a magnet after every work
trip he goes on it's cute and thoughtful
except he puts them on the fridge I've
tried to find another spot for them but
they always end up back on the fridge
we're moving from our apartment into our
first house soon and the magnets just
simply don't fit the aesthetic what do I
do should I lose them during the move
much love well sorry she wrote her name
oh my God nobody ever writes their name
much love magnet girl that is so
interesting because it's so sweet but I
totally understand like we cannot be
having a fridge full of magnets but if
they're not gonna be on the fridge like
they're just gonna sit in a drawer which
is also kind of sad like those are gifts
from him
for me like I am of Jackie and Ben they
both call me the sweeper like I'm
constantly sweeping up get throwing
things out like I don't care if they
have sentimental value like I hate
clutter in my house I find myself like
you know months later looking for stuff
and being like Oh my God I definitely
tossed that in the sweep so I'm just
very much like I don't care about your
feelings it's you know it's how the
house looks over your feelings this is
like a really sweet thing maybe you
could put them in like a shoe box no or
like put them in a drawer and then when
you need a magnet on the fridge like for
a grocery list like take from the magnet
drawer but we're not just gonna have
like magnets on the fridge that aren't
serving a purpose no yeah that's like
very like old retro like it's it's tacky
like it's not the vibe you could be like
going into the new home like I want
purposeful magnets and they're not just
gonna sit on the fridge like if you want
a grocery list or you're leaving me a
note like this is the Magna drawer do
people still use magnets like are fridge
is still magnetic I feel like the new
like vibe that was people having like
cabinets over their fridge yeah so most
people don't actually have magnetic
fringes I think my fridge is magnetic
but I don't have a magnet right is that
still a thing I guess like when you have
kids and they start like coming home
with like paintings and like you have
the kids schedule on the fridge it's no
it's cute but like I feel like it's not
like a nice magnets for magnet's sake
right no I mean I don't have children so
like I certainly don't have a single
magnet in my home purposeful magnets is
where we're going in 2023 just be like
oh my God I was listening to this
podcast they were talking about
purposeful magnets yeah yeah and it
really got me thinking like our magnets
are not serving a purpose and until they
do they should go in a drawer they're
just kind of like cluttering but did you
see that story about Marine condo she's
kind of like given up yeah that was sad
that was sad and like a real reflection
of the state of the world it made me sad
to think of everybody who threw their
stuff away and is now like oh I want it
back they got carried away they got
condoed away but I still like her
philosophy yeah but if it doesn't spark
Joy get rid of it but I don't know I
feel like this might be a hard sell now
that like Marie kondo is valid out but
maybe we need a new Marie condo called
the sweeper
new show idea I am the Claudia ashrae is
the sweeper your superpower is sweeping
it really is but that's why my studio
remains completely organized and clutter
free my house you will not find a single
thing I don't actually need and it's
it's one of the great joys of my life
sweeping I love it I I swept your house
last night whenever I'm still eating
today it's fun to sweep when it's just
like the Kid's Choice because they just
like all go back in the bin it's like
and it it goes from being like so messy
to so clean so it's easy to clean when
it's like yeah and you're also really
good you have like bins for Bruno's
Choice bins for Harry's toys like it's
easy to sweep your house yeah I just
felt like it was like really messy and
like Zach was going to come home like
it's not nice you know oh thanks I mean
it's that's a fun mess that's not like
really messy that's not like dishes in
this thing no I also would like to be a
good house guest so it's not like a
Claudia's coming like Ben's toenail
Ben's toenails did you ever tell that's
right I don't think that we did I worked
so hard when I say Jackie's has to to be
a good house guest like so that it's not
like oh Claudia is coming so like I know
you'll never feel that way but like I
don't want to act to be like oh so much
work Claudia's coming so I always you
know I never leave a dish when I leave I
you know make the bed every morning I
leave that the room nice I take my trash
out
and I do it for me and Ben yeah
but they stayed here in December and
when we were cleaning out the room
because we were turning it over for the
next guest we found Ben's toenail on the
nightstand like you know when like your
big toe like like just the whole thing
comes off right not like the whole nail
the whole like extension like yeah yeah
the whole like tip and so he must have
ripped it off and left it on the
nightstand because he must have been
impressed like with his big big toenail
I actually I remember him ripping it off
and jumping into pain oh really yeah it
never occurred to me he would leave it
there then he left it there and Zach
found it I feel like if I had found it
like I would have concealed and just
told you but Zach was it's so disgusting
it's like all the work that I do to like
leave a good impression for my family
and Ben destroys it with a two inch nail
and so I call Ben oh my God and you told
me to scare him so I left him like a
really scary voicemail like hey Bam we
need to talk like please call me back
and when he called him Yak I was like
you know dragging it out and then I was
like and I found your toenail and he was
like
no that's not mine that was Claudia's oh
what you didn't tell me that yes I did
he said that's Claudia's I was like no
it's too big to be Claudius on your side
of the bed yes or to the window right of
course and Claudia was an emperor oh
I cannot anyways he was like not even
giving you like not apologizing like not
embarrassed I cannot be like
relationship well I guess if it's mine
I'm sorry if it's that's like if I hurt
your feelings I'm sorry yeah he's like I
don't think it's mine but if it is like
I'm really sorry I cannot believe that
little [__] tried to blame me
well I'm like mad at him all over again
um I actually had forgotten about it
back to the deer toasters just
just get rid of them like I'm sorry put
them in a shoe box like it's sweet it's
like collector oh yeah we're in the mood
don't throw them away but like in the
move they don't have to go on the fridge
like put them somewhere where he can't
find them and then also maybe going
forward be like I feel like there's so
many magnets like but I'd love that
you're always thinking of me like maybe
a shot glass maybe keychain yeah change
switch it up switch it up maybe a
sweatshirt our next one is like a venmo
issue and I find these issues like
people really have such Gall right hey
Jackson Claude
token gen Z are here Claude your Tick
Tock presence is working my big sis
introduced me to the toast and I'm
obsessed that's why I wanted to read the
submission anything for me
no
usually like there's something nice for
you and something nice for me well she
didn't say something she just said The
Tick Tock presence is working since I'm
the one doing The Tick Tock oh okay I
thought she meant also like your videos
like you know your food trying no no I
think she just meant the clips because
she found out about us from her sister
it wasn't just like nice piece for both
of us as some people do
I need your advice I just moved to
Denver for work I'm in the process of
making new friends a few new girls
invited me and two of my friends from
home to go skiing this past weekend and
it was a blast we totally hit it off and
I could see us moving past the dreaded
friend dating phase but my dilemma is
that after the weekend was over the girl
who drove requested a venmo for gas and
parking totally normal and then she
requested a 35 uh venmo request per
person for one an exterior and interior
car detail and two a payment to rent a
spot on her car's ski rack her blatant
explanation was that if I charge ten
dollars to every person to bring their
skis per trip to the mountains I can
then pay off my ski rack by the end of
the season so she's just using these
girls like to pay her back to pay for a
ski rack I'm not sure what that is a ski
rack that you would already have yeah
that she like wants to pay off am I
pettiest [__] for not wanting to pay
this girl an extra 35 dollars that she
can pay for her own car upgrades on the
one hand it's not worth losing a new
friend over 35 dollars but she knows we
are all on a shoestring budget and and
skiing is as is expensive if I pay her
does this fuel this kind of behavior how
would you approach this
so I guess she bought a ski rack for her
car and then if she charges everyone ten
dollars then she's like she never had to
buy it yeah even though they did use it
but no more interior and exterior detail
that's definitely like extreme extreme
but but you know maybe she needed it
yeah like yeah I would just pay it too
and like going forward
there will be a time when like you won't
want to pay it and it doesn't make sense
to you but like if you want this person
as your friend just pay it
um but I do think this is a problem
that's going to persist but maybe
eventually like it will be something so
crazy that you could say something I
don't know I kind of feel like this
isn't the most unjustified request like
35 dollars when it was like the whole
weekend everyone used this one one
girl's car like skiing snow in the car
like the detail doesn't seem like that
crazy to me
um the ski rack is like a little hutzpah
like but it's like where would you guys
have put your skis right if she didn't
have her car and she didn't buy a ski
rack I don't know why it's like it's
very gray no no like it's
um
it's very like a small thing
but everybody's on like has bills to pay
and I mean it sounds like she would have
bought it regardless like she didn't buy
it like for you guys but
um I would I would pay it this time and
then just you know keep an eye out yeah
it doesn't honestly it's not the most
I've heard about crazier things people
asking for venmo requests yes I would
pay it this time for sure but like next
time be like okay what are the costs
gonna be up front the next time someone
asks you to do something like if we're
going to dinner like okay are there any
costs associated or just like we're
going to dinner but it's hard enough to
make friends in a new city so honestly
just like let this one go especially
because I don't feel like it's that
crazy yeah no it's not the craziest
thing I've ever heard
um all right our third and final dear
toasters dear Jackson Claude long time
listener here I hope all is well and
fabulous with both you and the boys
I recently had my first child and I
don't know how to tell my in-laws that I
don't want them posting pictures in
front of my child so I'm not making
giving the child a gender I don't want
them to be posting pictures of my child
on social media I feel like they're
going to roll their eyes and think I'm a
crazy mama bear behind closed doors I
don't like confrontation and I don't
want them to feel like I don't want them
to be a part of my child's life my
mother-in-law and sister-in-law post
everything and I mean everything on
Facebook and that's just not my journey
yeah my husband and I are more private
and we don't feel the need to overshare
our life I know my in-laws want to share
pictures of my newborn out of love and
excitement but I don't know how I feel
about my child having a digital
footprint at the moment here's the
kicker I want to be in charge of what
photos are posted and when I feel like
they will think it's hypocritical of me
if I tell them no posting and then I may
post a photo here or there down the line
what are your thoughts that's a very
well thought out submission totally
um I feel like you it have every right
to 100 I don't want my baby on social
media but you could also be like
especially I don't want like a lot of
volume of my baby out there but like
there if there's ever a photo that I'm
comfortable with you guys sharing like I
would let you know and like if I share
something that means that you can share
it too but I just just because there's
one picture doesn't mean that there's
not going to be a thousand floodgates
and they absolutely have to respect that
if they don't like
that's a problem
um and as far as you worrying about them
thinking you're like a crazy mama bear
behind closed doors like let them think
so what you care so much about their
grandchild it's better than them
thinking you're just like the deadbeat
mom like you know Jackie's totally right
there are such worse things for your
in-laws to think about you like if your
parents think if you're in-laws think
you're too overprotective over your
child that means you're doing a good job
like being overprotective is never a bad
thing when it comes to kids no never so
I agree like this is it is important
like it is worth having the conversation
over
you're not unjustified and nothing
you're asking for is like that crazy and
I feel like if you explain it out
especially like your sister-in-law who's
like younger like she should get it
other like parents don't really
understand like the full magnitude of
social media
um so I think you'd have to like explain
it to them more but as long as you do it
in a nice way yeah in a nice way not in
like a condescending way like you guys
share so much like yeah right right just
like this is me like for our family like
my uh your son agrees like we just don't
want a lot of pictures out there we'll
let you know if there's ever stuff we
feel a comfortable sharing but well did
you have to tell your in-laws yeah and
you totally understood yeah and I'm sure
that they would love like they would
love to be able to share pictures but
like of course they know and and they
respect 100 okay yeah oh I didn't
realize like that you literally did this
too yeah and so like you just said like
no picks yeah I said we're like we're
not sharing groups of Harry like please
don't share either no I guess I just
realized that too because I am friends
with your in-laws on Facebook and I've
never seen a picture of rodini right I
wish I would
um and like you didn't really have that
conversation with me because you know
like I would I'm so against it like the
world needs to say
yeah let's see what it's your turn what
you do no I know you know I've thought
about that a lot because like Olivia
didn't do it and then like you didn't do
it and I I don't know how I won't but I
think
I think I agree
the way that I felt like I always said
I'll see how I feel I'll see how I feel
and the way that I felt made my decision
for me but like the way that you you
might still feel like I don't see what
the big deal is and then you can share
by the way I do see what the big deal is
and I agree with your sentiments I just
feel sad for everyone else that they
will never get to experience the magic
but I just I feel like you'll the way
that you feel like it won't even be a
hard decision if you wind up posting or
not posting like yeah you'll know yeah
you'll know you'll know that's how I
felt I'm also just like a loser follower
like whatever my sisters do I do do you
know what I mean yeah so like the
decision's already been made I don't
know but sometimes you go Rogue I do
sometimes go wrong but not with
important [__] like kids are important I
don't know I could see you going just
being like no I feel fine no I don't I
couldn't see that actually really yeah
okay but again you're totally entitled
to the girl who wrote it not to make
everything about us
um you're completely entitled but I
think that's why she wrote into us like
yeah I I picked up on that oh I totally
because it didn't apply to me and if it
doesn't apply to me I'm not even paying
attention I didn't even pick up that
like you literally did this yeah yeah
yeah and it was totally fine yeah so
like unless you have like evil in-laws
which it sounds like they're pretty
normal like they love your kid and like
want to take pics so I think you'll be
fine yeah and I think a lot of people do
understand even if they've not
experienced it but they can conceive of
like the downsides of social media and
like especially for young kids like
there is a lot there
so I feel like they'll respect your
decision yeah I agree because we all
wants what's best for the child of curse
that's what we all have in in Kirman in
Kerman what are we gonna have for lunch
I literally just got so hungry I heard
somebody downstairs over the microwave
that's why I'm so glad you asked the
question I'm starving maybe like we go
out for lunch I also need to go to
Target because the way I have asked
repeatedly for a chair in my bathroom I
cannot you know what I didn't realize I
guess I have a vanity at my house and I
have not done my makeup standing up do
you need a chair with a back or a poof I
just need something well you could
always take one from the dining table no
no I want like a it needs to be taller
taller so I just need to go to I need to
go to Target and get what I need like my
back my feet hurt like just standing up
and doing your hair and makeup when you
take as long as I do is back breaking
stuff yeah so maybe we'll go lunch and
then Target I have to edit the redheads
today new episode drops tomorrow we
recorded it yesterday and it's so good
and even though we all like the book
like we all had a lot of really valid
concerns okay and I feel like it's a
really good episode about a great book
which so many people loved including the
Galleries and as always the rating felt
right but we were like not just blindly
eating all of it up because you could
have because there was it honestly she's
like real life Evelyn Hugo yeah it was a
really good book um but we have concerns
and I have concerns too about what I'm
gonna have for lunch so I'm gonna go
figure that out I'm gonna have a bowl of
strikes for lunch uh I hope you guys
have an amazing hump day thank you so
much for joining us and I hope it's time
for your lunch now or dinner whenever
you're listening to this or dessert
because I want my dinner now I do I do
want my dinner now thank you so much for
listening to the testimony Morning Show
where we deliver the festive stories you
need to remember Monday through Friday
on YouTube if you're watching this on
YouTube please subscribe give this video
a thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast and we're podcasts can be found
so it's Spotify
and wickedly talented we are uh
love you bye